[Musik]
am morgen stehe ich um zwanzig nach 7
auf dann gehe ich ins badezimmer
ich mache die tür auf und gehe unter die
dusche
ich
chef
danach ziehe ich die kleider an
ich trinke kaffee und lese die zeitung
ich steige in
dann fahre ich zur arbeit
ich komme um viertel vor neun im büro an
ich arbeite kunden an
ich unterschreibe dokumente ich
beantworte e mails um viertel nach vier
ist feierabend
danach hoffe ich im supermarkt ein
zu hause koche ich das abendessen
ich lade freunde zum essen ein
danach räume ich das wohnzimmer auf und
wasche das geschirr ab
dann sehe ich wäre der film fängt um
halb neun an
er schläft beim fernsehen ein
ich bin müde
ich gehe ins bett ich schalte das licht
aus
gute nacht
[Musik]